the Joe Rogan experience yeah that's all
so is it hard as an act or two if you
get an iconic role and then you are sort
of always remembered for being that guy
in that thing like how much of a is is
it a hard transition to go from an
iconic role to going into your next role
but people still want to talk about the
the the big movie that you were in just
a year or two ago mmm it's never that
hasn't been a big thing for me I I think
I take I tend to take a bit of time
between things and also I don't know
when I you don't like the first thing I
did what kind of popped off pretty hot
and then and then everyone's like
sending me like this you know it's like
it's psychotic
right psychotic interesting characters I
was like well I think I'll do a musical
with Woody Allen you know what I mean
and wear a plaid jacket and yeah do a
dance number in his Winston's like which
is uh yeah or and and then what's really
weird is I did that first I did I played
this lawyer I played the young lawyer in
the Larry Flynt film right which and
alpha that I got I get this distinct
vibe of like hey the next John Grisham
movie is kind of like the way you were
talking in court in that movie you would
kill and this John Grisham thing as the
young lawyer or whatever and I'm and I
remember I met Francis Coppola was gonna
direct the Rainmaker this Grisham thing
and I was up for it I didn't get it Matt
Damon got it and I didn't do some ballsy
thing and like say that's not for me I
was like I was like Francis Coppola I
was like I want this you know yeah I
think but when I was talking to him
about it and thinking to myself a little
bit like this seems a little square but
it's like Francis Coppola you know what
I mean and it's like and and he when I
was talking to him about it he was like
well what you know what what are you in
truth
what do you
working on what you interested in and I
was telling him about my friend David
who had written this Americans GX and
that we were working on I was kind of
telling him what we were trying to do
with it and how he wanted to make it is
this kind of like guerrilla you know
saying and and he was like you should do
that you should do that immediately and
I was like well I wanted I I was like
don't don't I was like don't cancel
don't don't you know I still want to do
this with you he's like no no I think
you should do you like the way you're
talking about that and he said if you do
that now they'll never they'll never
know what to do with you like they'll
never they'll never be able to put you
in a box kind of because that's just you
know if you pull that off and and I kind
of was like I you know it
I did have an agent at the time it was
really old school really funny and he
was kind of like he didn't understand
now he was like he was like fine
something big let's find something big
big director big film big franchise
whatever and I I remember thinking like
nah I think I'm going to do this and I'm
and we knocked that off and the funny
thing did you say well does that become
a trap it that wasn't a trap that was
like a liberation it's almost like doing
that part it was like a permanent hand
grenade on it was like net it was like
well we never know what to expect now
right so it becomes like liberation on
us at a certain point cuz like I weigh
150 you know like I'm not big so like
once you do something like that it's
sort of like mmm where did this guy's
this guy's this guy's kinky what the
hell are we gonna do with him you know
what I mean right
and then it's just sort of like you get
to decide for yourself in a way
[Applause]